- [Voiceover] If lowercase
x is a member of capital X,
lowercase y is a member of set capital Y,
and lowercase z is a
member of set capital Z,
which of the following
could have a value of 23?
So let's look at each of these.
So x times y times z.
So you take something from this set,
something from this set,
and something from that set,
and multiply them together.
Well, if you did that, you're going
to get a non-prime number.
Maybe you pick one from set X,
but then you're gonna have to pick a two
from set Y, or three or four,
and then a three, four, five.
So you're going to get things
like one times two times three
or one times three times three.
No matter what, especially when you look
at these last two sets, you're
going to get the product
of at least two primes or you
might even take the product
of a composite and a
prime or two composites.
So there's no way multiplying those three.
Especially a member from these last sets,
they don't have one in them.
But you're going to get
a prime number like 23.
23's factors are clearly
only 23 and itself.
It doesn't have a two or
three or four as a factor.
It doesn't have a five as a factor.
And so, we could rule that out.
Let's think about it, x plus y plus z.
Can we make that equal to 23?
So let's see, 23 is a lot
larger than these numbers.
Let's see if we'd pick the largest number
in each of these sets and
see if we can get to 23.
So three plus four plus five.
These are the largest
members in each of those sets
and this still only gets us to 12.
So there's no way we're going
to be able to get to 23.
Now at C, x plus y times z.
x plus y times z.
Well, I see a way of doing that.
I see a way of doing that.
x plus y times, let me do
this in a different color,
x plus y times z.
What if...
Let's see, we can get to 20 by multiplying
four times five and then you add a three.
So this could be three plus
four times five.
And so we'll go with that one.
Which of the following
could have a value of 23?
That one, and we can only pick one choice
so we know we're already done.
But we could verify that we can't
get there with these other ones.
So let's see, x squared plus
y squared plus z squared.
This one is tempting.
It's tempting.
This is because you could
get numbers large enough.
But if you play around
enough, you would have trouble
finding a combination that has a 23.
x times y plus z.
So, if you wanted to get
as large as possible,
you do three times four.
So you could try three times
four and then plus some z.
But then in this case, this
is going to be 12 plus z.
12 plus z.
z would have to be nine.
You don't find a nine in this third set.
There's clearly no nine so you could
rule that one out as well.
So we go at C.